right we are ivan for another reading
from my 2011 book
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
as always we'll do some reading and then
after that we'll have some time for q a
and discussion with whatever people
put into the chat do try to make it
relevant to the
book the topic the thinkers
and the issues that are being discussed
we have ama sessions for more general
questions or
things like that
so i'm um
about halfway through
emil brahier's um contribution to the
debates which is his article
is there a christian philosophy
from the reviewed metaphysique et de la
morale in 1931 this is one of the
early pieces in the debate and it's good
to remind ourselves that brahir was also
a young up and coming historian of
philosophy at the time the original
debate was supposed to be
uh brejier and brunchfig versus jillson
and mara 10 and then a lot of other
people jumped into it and bruh here
represents what we typically call the
rationalist set of positions on
christian philosophy also mention that
the whole thrust of brahir's position as
we will see at the end of this piece is
to say that there is no such thing as
christian philosophy because it couldn't
possibly
exist
so
i'm picking up here at section 3. of his
article is there a christian philosophy
in the works of its great metaphysicians
descartes mal braj leibniz the 17th
century shows us a completely new
attempt at synthesis between philosophy
and christianity
to speak truly historians of philosophy
up to the 20th century had almost
completely neglected the religious
aspects of these doctrines
granted everyone knows that descartes
personally had a living faith and the
truths of faith remain as he says
first in his belief
but this faith like that of montaigne
seems to be entirely custom and habitude
it is juxtaposed to a philosophy that
itself is rational and grounded on a
universal method
for nearly 20 years more scrupulous and
more detailed historical research has
transformed somewhat the perspective in
which these great systems appeared
rationalism's being directed towards a
christian meaning corresponds to that
general
movement of minds that beginning with
the counter-reformation
and the council of trent adopts the
counter-position
uh contrappied to the renaissance in the
question of the relations of philosophy
and faith
throughout the 16th entire 16th century
we see that thought oscillate between
two opposed positions an anti-christian
rationalism or an anti-rationalist
christian faith
on the one side of the poduans according
to whom the aristotelian philosophy for
them representing independent reason
arrives on the most important questions
notably on immortality of the soul or
the possibility of miracles and results
opposed to christianity
on the other side a montan for whom
reason is powerless to affirm anything
or deny anything with certainty it
cannot be an enemy or an aid for
religion it is too weak for that
both parties agree to completely
separate philosophical thought from
religion
at one ending up in a rational
construction incompatible with religion
the other being unable to see a serious
opponent in feeble reason
in the 17th century everything changes
then devoted humanism studied by the
abbe bremont in least juar de santo
religious or
deceptive siak brings itself forth in
this synthesis of faith and rationalism
christians claim to turn on the
libertines the very weapon they'd used
against religion that is reason they
wanted reason consulted impartial
impartially to end up establishing not
of course christianity's mysteries which
can only be revealed but at least it's
fundamental truths the existence of an
infinite and creator god and the
immortality of the soul
it is then that this quite new campaign
against the libertines
begins in which one agrees with them in
order to exalt reason's power but
diverges completely
from them
in in one's conclusions
skepticism appeared then just as much to
be feared as the atheist's rationalism
would it be true as frequent attempts
have been made to demonstrate in recent
years that descartes
meditations themselves fit into the
current of christian rationalism and
that they should be a manifestation of
it or even a manifesto
it is certain that descartes does
everything to emphasize in the eyes of
the public and above all the theologians
his philosophy's christian character
do we therefore see then the birth of
this christian philosophy whose
existence we are seeking
that was not the opinion of certain
contemporaries of descartes and not the
least important of them pascal
reproached the proofs descartes gives of
the existence of god with being sterile
and useless for the only thing that
matters to the christian religion for
salvation
as an apologist pascal encountered on
his way this rationalist apologetic
which was imputed to descartes and this
is what he thought quote the
metaphysical proofs of god's existence
are so remote from the reasoning of men
and so complicated that they make little
impression if they should be of service
to some
it would be only in the moment that they
see such demonstration but an hour
afterwards they fear they have been
mistaken
he attacks not the truth of these proofs
but their opportunists
descartes and those whom he followed
overestimate the condition of human
nature by making reason the introduction
to faith
but supposing
that because of rational proofs the
conviction of god's existence can be
firm in us
does it follow that the philosophy that
employs them
leads to christianity
christianity is the belief in a mediator
and redeemer christ and the knowledge of
god without christ pascal thinks is a
knowledge of pure curiosity and useless
to salvation
curiosity
superbia a miserant this is the result
of the knowledge of god obtained without
jesus christ it is communion without a
mediator with the god whom they've known
without a media mediator
history shows pascala to have been right
here descartes metaphysics goes in the
direction of what has been called
natural religion that is the totality of
truths that man can acquire about god
and the soul by reason this natural
religion common to all men independent
of any positive or revealed religion
leads so little onto the path to
christianity that it becomes a weapon
for fighting against it in the 18th
century the necessity of a mediator who
is christ of a revelation of a church
that guards the deposit of that
revelation this is what jean-jacques
rousseau declares useless when he writes
in the profession de fuerado vicero
savayard
what men between god and myself
should we not have to see here the
cartesian point of views normal
culmination
if we recall how he arrives at god after
having excluded by methodological doubt
everything other than his own thought
this would be a setback if descartes
goal was truly to support christianity
but it is not that to make apologetics
descartes goal is to forget that
metaphysics is part of a vaster
philosophy completely oriented towards
physics and morals this would be to
reduce the meditations to the
proportions of the treaties like that of
father mercen against the impiety of the
atheists and deus there again pascal has
seen the truth quote i cannot forgive
dickhart in all his philosophy he would
have been quite willing to dispense with
god
but he had to make him give a phillip to
set the world in motion beyond this he
has no further need of god
in descartes works theology has the
place that's assigned to it by method
and it is by accident that it is served
for the propagation of the christian
religion
but this rationalism is it not christian
at least in the thomas sense that is in
the sense that it is ready to accept
revealed theology's censorship did
descartes not have the same opinion as
saint thomas on the relations between
reason and faith did he not seek to
demonstrate for example that his theory
of matter is not in disagreement with
the dogma of the real presence this
agreement in principle with tomism
cannot however go very far
so different are the conceptions of
reason in the two doctrines
to a reason that reaches only the
abstractions of sensible things that
discusses and argues more than it
demonstrates descartes opposes a reason
both intuitive and demonstrative
it has its own object completely
distinct from sensible things even more
it is capable of discovering truths not
only discussing theses so understood
reason has a perfect autonomy it is a
source of certainty by itself it is not
at all that weak obscure reason only
disengage slightly from sensations which
would have to fold before revelation
it is incontestable that this cartesian
reason is the one animating spinozas and
maul brush as doctrines assuredly both
have quite tangled relations with
christianity
still it is enough that they accept at
their starting point the principle of
clear and distinct ideas in order for
them not to merit any more than the
cartesian philosophy the name of
christian philosophy
in summary
tomism and cartesianism show us the two
ways that christian rationalism could
take ways that end up nowhere either as
in tomism's case a censure of authority
and revelation is enforced and is only
through experience and being disciplined
that one finds the place of reason this
puts rationalism in a more than
precarious situation and at the limit
annihilates it
or as in descartes case it is a matter
of irrationalism that decisively sets
the conditions a certainty of a reason
having in itself the intrinsic proof of
its own truth
and then faith censorship no longer has
any kind of meaning
so much that it is meaningless to call
it christian rationalism
all right now we move on to
section four of brahir's is there a
christian philosophy
in the 18th century when one says
philosophy one says anti-christianism
and later laminae designates by the word
philosophism every doctrine that rejects
revelation as a source of certainty the
theologians for their part stopped
looking for a support and truths of
religious order in the natural light it
is not necessary for our purpose wrote
paley for example in 1802 with respect
to the immortality of the soul that
these propositions be susceptible of
proof or even that by the assistance of
arguments drawn by the natural light
they could go beyond the probable it is
sufficient that we can say they are not
so improbable that one ought to reject
on first examination the propositions or
the facts united to them also the
christian philosophy born in the 19th
century in intimate relations with the
assaults the preceding century's
doctrines underwent is no longer the
rationalism of the 13th or 17th century
they now attempt a fusion between reason
and faith more intimate than in other
times it is in faith itself that the
means by which reality represents itself
are sought
this state of mind has since the end of
the 18th century especially in france
and germany so numerous and so varied
expressions we cannot dream of even
following out its main currents let us
indicate at least two great divisions
that will allow introducing a bit of
order into this confusion
sometimes christianity takes on the
aspect of a social bond the only one
capable by its divine origin of
disciplining human nature and creating
the fundamental institutions that
produce humanity
and at other times it takes on the
aspect of a revelation of the entire
history of the universe
the only revelation capable of giving
our life a meaning and an orientation in
both cases what is striking
is the archetectonic systematic
constructive character that one lends
christianity by opposition to the
anarchic freedom wanted by the century
of the revolution here this is a
completely new way of seeing things
it is no longer a question of divvying
out truths of two orders in christianity
those accessible to reason and those
that are not
one grasps in it in its concrete
totality as a living faith and as one
speculative and practical capable of
directing intellects and wills
let us consider now the first aspect in
the words and the works of a demised
debunaled alamone
everywhere the philosophy of the 18th
century sees a human work an autonomous
construction modifiable by rational
means
these thinkers see a divine work as
necessary as it is incomprehensible to
reason
when's the feeling of an absolute fact
of experience that one cannot analyze a
trait that gives to certain of demise
passages a character fidelity to data to
positivity which christian philosophy of
the 19th century shields itself politics
he says for example quote
presents a rather strange phenomenon
quite apt to make any wise man call to
the administration of states tremble it
is that nearly everything that common
sense perceives at the start in this
science as an evident truth is almost
always found once experience has spoken
to be not only false
but detrimental to begin with the most
basic
if everyone has heard discussions about
government and men being called to
deliberate for example about hereditary
or elective monarchy one would regard a
person who would determine themselves
for the former is senseless history
however which is experimental politics
demonstrates that hereditary monarchy is
the most stable the most fortunate the
most natural to man one perceives the
close link between this christian
thought and a conservative politics that
sees in the very duration of a
constitution the witness of an origin
independent of human will
if the base is purely human says joseph
de meiste again the edifice cannot hold
and the more that human affairs are
mixed up in it the more they engage in
deliberation about science and writings
especially the more fragile the
institution will be
if reason still retains some value it is
under the condition of not wanting to be
anything other than a form of tradition
and its oldest aspect
this christian philosophy the better to
dominate reason annexes it thus into
revelation
it is the bonald who assures that the
former is only a species of the second
reason he says is impossible without
communication of beings with each other
without society and this communication
is in its turn impossible without
language but according to him the
absurdity of assumptions one would have
to make if one thinks language is a
human invention shows it would have to
be revealed by god to man and with it
the reason it
contains in such doctrines
religion divinely revealed passes more
and more for having that character of
universality and unity that was formerly
conferred on reason
according to laminae
reason left to itself would end up only
in skepticism and it divides people to
the contrary there has been only one
single religion that presented itself
under three forms progressing from one
to the other that of the patriarchs that
of moses and that of christ and the
pagan religions were only deformations
of this unique revelation
for the early laminae the main concern
is absorbing all of humanity's powers
into religion the rift between
christianity and science a rift for
which he does not hesitate to hold
responsible the clergy who confused the
errors of a radically atheist philosophy
with what was right and pure in the
cause they upheld
appears to him one of the most important
reasons for the weakening of religion in
france
one sees how christian philosophy of
this kind is born from the conviction
that christianity alone responds to
demands everyone felt after the
revolutionary torment for unity for
organization for fixity
this substitution of the catholicity of
christianity for the universality of
reason
does it respond to some true reality
let us muse about the evolution of
laminae himself who instructed by
experience saw little by little the
unity he dreamed of unravel
for him as for all the thinkers of his
party christianity is not a speculative
doctrine but a historical reality a
church governed by the papacy so he asks
in the affair de rome what became in
france and germany and poland even of
the power that had exercised over mines
at other times
has it modified opinion there in some
way moved the public conscience forget
the clicks and their miseries look to
the masses
where are those who the papacy directs
and moves
by the demands of his thought and his
action
laminae is thus pushed out of an
unresponsive christianity to historical
christianity to catholicism that
abandons its mission to protestantism an
illegitimate inconsequent narrow system
he opposes an ideal christianity a
religion of the future
his traditionalism his historical
realism transforms into an idealism
this transformation makes explicit
the nature of the kind of christian
philosophy we're studying the demand of
christianity not a truth
but a resistant principle of social
organization first they persuade
themselves there's an intimate union
between a dogma and authority from the
fact of the papacy when they perceive
that this union is less solid they
thought they'll seek another principle
of unity traditionalism's true offspring
is the positivism of auguste
who reestablishes all the social values
of catholicism understanding of social
value the power of unification without
retaining anything of dogma itself
the 18th century by wrecking
christianity from the intellectual point
of view
wrecked its social power for compt it's
a matter of re-establishing a social
power just as strong and an unshakable
intellectual base this endpoint of
joseph de meiste and de donald's
traditionalism sufficiently proves that
in this christian philosophy
christianity plays the part of a
historical
accident
it is ready to cede place to another
dogma as soon as the circumstances
change
now we move on to section five
such as the christian philosophy of the
19th century's philosophy the social
bond let us now see what in it is in
germany and above all in hegel's works a
speculation on the universe he declared
many times that the christian religion
was an indispensable
moment in the development of the human
mind
and the necessary prelude to philosophy
religion and philosophy of the same
content only religion quote has this
content in a religious way that is under
the form of representation and we must
distinguish representation and
conceptual thought religion is the
universal consciousness of spirit in
general and it is then that spirit
becomes for the first time the object of
a consciousness that is sensible and
representative but it is in philosophy
that it exists as a concept and only
philosophy moves itself in this form of
thought
this common content is the synthesis or
unity of opposites
in the christian religion it is
presented under the form of christ the
mediator who reconciles man with god
quote it has its very beginning in an
absolute cleavage and there is felt need
only in cleavage
therefore this cleavage of the subject
of the ego from the infinite absolute
essence drives spirit back into itself
this reconciliation occurs in faith in
the form of revelation
it is christ the savior who is the
reconciler between the existence of man
finite and detached from god by original
sin and the essence of man which is not
different from the infinite
philosophy only quote recognizes this
content in liberating from the exclusive
form it had in religion and by raising
it to the absolute form that is if one
permits
us a somewhat free translation by
transforming the christian myth into an
essential law of reality the christian
myth is the totality of the divine
history that goes from creation to the
return of god by passing through the
original sin that distances man from god
and by the redemption that brings him to
god again
it becomes the law of the real sense
according to the hegelian dialectic we
see spirit go out from itself and
disperse itself in nature in order to
return to itself by an inverse movement
whose moments are the diverse forms of
the life of humanity consciousness
itself law mores morality religion and
art
there is nothing more habitual to the
german mind than such a transformation
hegel's philosophy is one form new
without a doubt but a form of the same
fundamental thought that had been
translated since the middle ages by
eckart and later yakubuma nobody more
than hegel had been convinced that so
interpreted the christian mind marks a
very deep decision in the history of
humanity in christianity quote man is an
end by himself there is an infinite
value in him and he is destined to
eternity he has his fatherland
in a super sensible world and an
infinite exteriority that he reaches
only by breaking with natural existence
and volition and working towards that
rupture
in hellenism man loses himself in the
object of his contemplation in
christianity the subject knows itself as
such quote in it is the individual the
subject the welfare of the soul the
salvation of the individual as an
individual is the essential purpose
this is the beginning of the movement
that leads to absolute spirit this
subjectivity this selfhood not
selfishness
is precisely the principle of cognition
itself
that is how in this translation
the man-god of christian dogma is less a
historical reality than a symbol
of the infinity that human beings find
in themselves but their christian
philosophy disappears
just as joseph de meisten de donald's
christianity ended up in colt's
sociocracy hegel's philosophy ends up in
that of feuerbach
from demise christianity comprehends the
idea of the social necessity of a dogma
that unifies minds of hegelianism
feuerbach retains the idea of the
infinite power that is in humanity and
that contains in itself the reason
imminent to all its manifestations or
history
in both cases
by where it ends up christian philosophy
has revealed what it was from the
beginning a humanism
in
uh in both cases
one perceives that the christian
religion in what is positive in it does
not respond to what this latent humanism
demanded of it it is only a means for it
and this means was found to be imperfect
the end which is human society and
culture
seemed incorrectly embodied by this
means which is abandoned once it is
found lacking
this attitude resigned in some cases or
challenging in others which leads to the
human mind the care for its own destiny
has been the starting point for the last
of the forms of christian philosophy
that we have to point out
we know how by the very analysis of
human action grasped by as such by its
imminent characters mr blondel has tried
to draw out a justification of the
christian faith and more specifically of
the catholic faith in oxio 1893 quote
the time has come he wrote in 1896 for
the truly catholic idea to show its
power and to promote a philosophy which
is appropriate to it
it is not then a matter of knowing if
philosophy is something existing in
itself is in agreement with christian
dogma but rather of bringing to birth
the philosophy of christianity itself
still one must recognize that mr
blondel's doctrine has much more of a
familial relation with an apologetics
than with philosophy
his procedure is well known enough a
critique of action parallel in a certain
sense with the critique of knowledge and
kant's work
kant found himself faced with
rationalists such as leibniz or
descartes who admitting a perfect ad
equation between knowledge and its
object
gave to the human intelligence a divine
sufficiency and he showed that this
adequation did take place but on the
condition that this object be an object
relative to our modes of knowing and
defined by them whereas knowledge
grasped as a whole is inadequate to
reality one can also consider action
under two points of view
speaking technically an action couldn't
correspond exactly to its end and
produce precisely what we'd wanted to
produce if one seeks to make all the
activities of man fit into technical
activities if one conceives as possible
as spencer for example does a certain
perfection of action that leaves nothing
to be desired but experience
shows us that an action never responds
to our deep needs that there is no
action that does not bring to birth
needs it does not satisfy provoking
other actions and thus to infinity mr
blondel insists on the feeling of
dissatisfaction of inquiet in this quote
state of perpetually unstable
equilibrium or of intimate just infant
intimate disproportion that always
leaves us in quest of something else in
his work the word action designates not
only the known realization of conscious
tendencies but also obscure virtualities
and latent power implicit anticipations
and confused presontimon
he opposes in short the true will which
is latent to the apparent and expressed
will
and he demonstrates that the objects
that satisfy the apparent will do not
satisfy our real will
in this endless aspiration man must make
an option either he wills to confine
himself to what experience supplies him
with and then his will remains
unsatisfied and impotent
or
he can sense to detach himself from
objects that cannot satisfy his will and
then it is possible for him to obtain
the equilibrium of power and willing why
not choose the second does man pretend
to will infinitely without willing the
infinite
it is clear the that the problem of
action as mr blondel raises it does not
have any special relation to
christianity it very closely resembles
the problem of serenity and the
tranquility of the soul which so
occupied ancient thought and for which
stoics epicureans and skeptics had
proposed solutions that nothing keeps
one from believing just as viable as mr
blondel's solution and this is why we
say that it is a matter of apologetics
and not philosophy it is a matter of
introducing and defending christian
doctrine considered as proved and
verified elsewhere and even of making
one desire it but this convenience is
not an argument in its favor
why should we believe that the reality
of things is such that our deep will
should be satisfied why should we why
would we believe that it cannot be
satisfied except by christian revelation
it is not there at all that we will find
a christian philosophy
definitively then
we have not encountered christian
philosophy not in saint augustine who
decisively separates the word made flesh
from the reason of the philosophers nor
in saint thomas who leaves reason only a
precarious existence
nor among the rationalists of the 17th
century whose doctrine tending towards
natural religion loses all contact with
christianity
nor with the philosophers of the 19th
century where we see christian
philosophy quickly deflect itself into a
humanism
it is by accident that during the
centuries of the middle ages
intellectual culture of greek origin was
closely tied to religious profession
philosophy at the end of antiquity was
platonist aristotle's rationalism
dominated the 13th century in the 17th
century a new intellectualism was born
issued from the greek genius
in the 19th century social problems
impose themselves by the antithesis of
sociocracy and individualism this
development is independent of
christianity it did not have the least
affinity with it we have seen
christianity's attempts always vain to
fix on one of these moments in order to
appropriate it but one can no more speak
of a christian philosophy than of a
christian mathematics
or a christian physics
and that is the end of
brahir's contribution is there a
christian philosophy published in the
review de mere physique morale in 1931
one of his main contributions to the
debates he also took part in the debate
itself in the 1931 meeting of the
society frances di philosophy but as
i've mentioned in the historical
introduction to this summarizing that he
essentially had his ass he had to do it
by jill so
if you like socratic dialogue where
socrates is taking his interlocutors
apart bit by bit you would probably
enjoy reading that unfortunately the
society frances d philosophy does not
allow anything more than the main
presentations and they made an exception
for blondel's letter which we're going
to read in a couple weeks to be
published in translation
but you can trust me on that if you can
get your hands on it it is quite a
discussion that they have back and forth
um so that concludes the first real
chapter of the translations in
um contained in my 19 i heard my 2011
book reason fulfilled by revelation the
1930s christian philosophy debates in
france i'm happy to take questions about
the book about uh
emil brejier about the other
interlocutors about the points he was
making trying to argue that there cannot
possibly be a christian philosophy
particularly when we look at the
uh claiming uh historical instantiations
of it
we will be doing um two more of these
this month two more readings i would
normally be doing
them every thursday but i next thursday
i'm going to be speaking
at stoicon norway about stoic stumbling
blocks
things that get in the way of beginners
studying stoicism and applying it
adequately so we'll we will be taking a
little hiatus from this and then we'll
be coming back to the the book
in the last two thursdays of the month
any questions comments
issues
people want to
ask about raise any of those those sorts
of things
well while people are writing things if
they are going to write things i i will
mention that brahe's argumentative
strategy is essentially to say
let's look to see whether
christianity
made any
decisive contributions to philosophy
and he picks out eras the patristic
through augustine era
the
time of medieval scholasticism using
thomas aquinas as the stand-in for that
as we heard today
the 17th century rationalism he doesn't
talk about the empiricists because
frankly he doesn't really care about
them too much
and then the 19th century where we have
the traditionalism of people who we
don't read anymore but probably should
be because a lot of the people doing
traditionalism today are just
regurgitating what those those thinkers
uh had to say you know laminae de bonol
de meiste
hegel he talks about and foyerbach and
then finally
goes after blondel directly blondel is
going to respond to him in
the piece that we're going to read in
three weeks from now
jill song will be the next person up
is um
[Music]
the notion of christian philosophy which
is a fairly short piece i think we can
get through that in one session
uh is there a christian philosophy took
us two sessions blondels does christian
philosophy exist as philosophy
um is a letter that was appended to that
in which he's going after blondel mostly
and then we'll be taking blondels is
there a christian philosophy all soon
they reviewed
a morale
um
and that's a response to brahir so we
have a question is the scottish common
sense philosophy ever mentioned by
anybody not in the debates because they
have
very little interest in that and you
know in the history of philosophy the
scottish common sense philosophy is sort
of a minor school sort of like the
cambridge platonists or you know um
it's sort of like uh if you think about
he he so bray here mentioned maul branch
you know very rarely are people who are
working
on
17th century philosophy
in anglo
countries discussing mall branch it's
usually descartes leibniz and and
spinoza but mall branch is equally
important so
yeah you know the the common sense
philosophers like thomas reed are just
not on their their radar
um
as a matter of fact they're not on the
radar of most uh english-speaking
philosophers at that time i would say as
well any other questions
comments um
issues that people want to
bring up
all right um
pratham says don't have any questions or
comments i want to thank you for the
works you've put up here on youtube
you've been a great help to me thanks
for i appreciate it yeah well thanks i'm
glad that the stuff has been helpful for
you um
it's been 10 years now or a little bit
more than 10 years i guess you could say
i started in spring of
2011.
um and you know i'm gonna do at least
another decade we'll see what youtube
turns into i mean who knows what the
platform will become
over the next decade but um
yeah it's uh you know it's something i
enjoy doing it's very helpful for my my
students
you can see you know i've got my little
studio behind me it's become part of my
way of life and way of doing philosophy
down the line when i actually have the
time i'll probably start doing some core
concept videos on
some of the
talks in there
um
all right here's another question is the
discussion of infinite desire rooted in
any sort of platonic arrows or is there
an effort explicitly to distance the
christian position from the ancients
neither
infinite desire can be understood in
many many different ways
it doesn't have to be rooted in platonic
eros platonic eros is not the one
stand-in for infinite desire
in the ancient period it's just one of
many different ways of looking at it
much of platonic eros is not infinite
desire
you can have eros
just for watching horses race or
something like that so there's a lot of
different ways to understand
desire and infinite desire and whether
desire is like provoked by the object or
whether it's like born within us you
know all of those
those sorts of things and it frankly is
not something discussed
thematically all that much
in these debates um they do reference
some authors earlier in the century like
gita broglie for example
important french
thomist who was um
you know digging into this question
there was kind of an open question
is the infinite desire for the infinite
something that is natural or
supernatural right so
there's there's that going on
any other questions comments people want
to
uh bring up
all right well
let me say uh thanks for the comments
and questions and for the attention um
book is
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
um
available from catholic university of
america press
it is so far sold you know in 10 years
about 500 copies which for an academic
book not too bad you know
probably i'm guessing half of those are
libraries purchasing it they they
unfortunately cua press priced it out of
a lot of people's price range if you go
above 50 bucks for a book people don't
want to want to get it
it was intended to be a research aid and
to help spread you know
what would you call interests and
awareness in the how wide the debates
were
and it kind of did that you know
i think i probably
need to return to these topics and do a
bit more
other writing that would be
um
popularizing these things because it's
really you know well worth studying
these documents the the idea the
questions the problems involved with the
notion of christian philosophy
they've really never been debated as
thoughtfully and with as many voices and
as intensively as they were during these
1930s debates um there have been some
advances beyond them bringing in things
say you know in phenomenology or people
talking about you know adrian pepperzak
is a great example of that
writing in the 1990s
but
they're sort of the touchstone i would
say and and some of the
writers involved in it like brahir great
stylist
it's fun to read his stuff you know just
because it's um so well put even though
i think he's wrong about stuff
um so i'll just leave it at that and say
goodbye to everybody uh see you next
time and thanks for
the conversation